[Music]
have you guys heard about witches
casting spells on white-supremacist oh
that's not heard of that
tick-tock witches is it working no I
guess so cuz they go I mean the cops got
charged so there's that
are there any minority witches I'm sure
yeah I'm sure there's all kinds of
witches there are white witches back
with you Mexican which is hell yeah I
saw that I was thinking like a good
witch or a bad witch and then you said
the Mexican which I was like Oh the
wicked witch from the east yeah the
Middle East
oh damn Jill why she gotta be evil
so you Creed the white guy over there a
white which is like Glendon was the good
white witch or whatever protests we're
starting I don't know if you guys know
this but it was a full moon mmm that
coincided with the protests making it
perfect for witches to a witchy allies
to show their support via their spells I
saw they came out with the Amish a true
yeah I like that mean that they're like
okay this only this
it only took witches the Amish
spider-man Batman and like they listed
everything that everyone did to like
finally charge these mothers so that was
like when you see the Amish in support
with the witch if that's what he no
shit's bad okay true the Amish actually
have been we're like back in the day
they helped a lot of slaves escape mm-hm
someone would just like they're all
protesting and someone was like how do
you guys even here I was thinking the
same thing grass we know they didn't
watch the video they put their ear to
the ground yeah mother nature speaks to
everyone what was that movie where the
guy stick the knife and wait so they can
hear the ground the oh [ __ ] the police
are beating people up okay besides there
are there are different communities that
live like in mountains or whatever they
have technology but I thought how much
have no technology yes electronic
technology just jumped into my sentence
I didn't say anything about technology
no but they do where they they go into
town they work and then they go back to
the communities oh I've seen the Amish
mafia
I'm gonna talk about armies bro what are
you talking about witches talk about you
talk about what
Amish she's different different these
real with other people that just dress
up BR the modern-day witches and they've
been sharing in incantations spells and
moon rituals on social media
particularly over tick-tock as a means
of protesting from their respective
homes sparking the hashtags hashtag
witches for BLM and hashtag which is
Against Racism so just to give you an
example of one of the tick-tocks that
have been circulating I love to talk
there's a lot of kind of teaching baby
witches who how to make their first
spells
[Music]
it froze the she cast a spell on the
video yeah it's probably a a bad wish
this is very witchy music to
[Music]
sign petitions doing it to be able to
educate amplify protest use your voice
oh so I'm a witch
you light a candle all meditate first Oh
cuz I was that way where's the spells at
yeah what you sick [ __ ] yeah what's your
wand was a cauldron that's dope though
they're being realistic
[Music]
oh there we go that's what we're waiting
for
could you date a girl that was like that
wait like one of these ones are real one
like this one he said which not oh I
heard [ __ ] oh you cast a spell in his
heart yeah so would you ever date away
maybe you know what if as long as she's
not just like casting spells on me and
[ __ ] but how do you know this just seems
like she's just meditating and lighting
candles yeah it's gonna come back times
3 if you do something like a dark magic
right yeah cuz I watched the craft hello
light as a feather stiff as a board
hello boy hello
I don't know star do you think witches
watch like Sabrina chosen like this is
like [ __ ] up well then you wonder the
old one cuz a new one scary scary oh god
oh my god oh let's see if she drowns
it's all that toad soup ibanez drinking
like you know Monty Python when they're
trying discuss it that she was a witch
or not and they're trying to use logic
and science under like if she's a witch
she will float something I feel like
witches probably watch like the Sabrina
and they're like oh this is such a witch
stereotype yeah it's crazy
they wish they could be they wish they
could be there influencer I mean do you
think which is all like look each other
like she's not an authentic way because
like there's certain wicked practices
that they do my friend was Wiccan for a
while and like so there's like that it's
like a religion it's a religion just
like any other religions no taxes I
don't know there's no church I I suppose
there would be tax exclusions I just
know that every girl who turned 14 in my
high school will turn Wiccan for like
five months yeah what does I mean they
bought those which books at Barnes &
Noble and they got like and do it for
did you do it no my friend did though we
had to grow that uh she owned those like
books that she would always like just be
here right in but it was it was like a
journal and she would act like she's
writing in it and that you like people
with a what the [ __ ] you're doing it's
you oh you can't see it Oh like hey she
wrote it in which ink I guess like only
she could see it another witches could
see it no I mean like I did like I like
spiritual things that can be like
sometimes alternative healing stuff is
considered witchy like chakra cleansing
or whatever and that's different than
Wiccan what's chakra is that chocolate
cleansing is that just drinking
pepto-bismol no no silly chakras in
alignment so there's like your base
chakra your creative chakra but what if
you got a tummy ache wouldn't you take
pepto-bismol first and then do a chakra
clean you should take you should for
sure take pepto-bismol if you need
pepto-bismol for like heartburn or stuff
what do you need pepto-bismol for your
chakras all stuffed yeah clear it out I
mean you could use pepto and then also
aligned your chakras after you clear it
out drinking with the shop and pepto
yeah do the moon water share right I
have not done moon water yet but people
Oh was it yeah she's a witch no but
she's that you know she's so like
experiment like dabble so yeah you
dabble it's like fun I charged my
retainer which and you did it with my
moonstone charges under that I did a
crystal lady I do charge my crystals oh
and the Sun and the moon
oh that's just cuz that's how you're
supposed to charge up all right let's do
this moon water [ __ ] next time I know I
keep mix what is it water whenever you
pull it yeah go ahead set go okay you go
when there's a moon you think there's
water and you put it on the side under
the moon and in charges chemical
position drink it yes the next day you
know [ __ ]
for how long forever idiot for how long
forever
does it also work the same way if you go
to a vending machine that's been
underneath the full moon and you order a
water four seals
yeah and you gotta have intentions put
on it I said directly what technically
all water has been under yeah like the
ocean the ocean yeah yeah the ocean is
very healing actually and it's charged
with salt which is positive ions you
could drown there too which well you're
not harnessing the power of the ocean
stupid [ __ ] you meant to say witch
who's a [ __ ] now no I meant to say
[ __ ] stupid baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ] bad
guys and which is back in my day I'm
back in your day in a 70s you just heard
everyone's feelings in this room the
deme are you proud of yourself back in
my day
your phase are here okay I'm shy do you
guys not found me that I really believe
in like superstitious witchcraft type
stuff I can't say I don't want to talk
about it have like cousins that are like
the laws so they're basically priests
for like loss what is that that's basic
what a priest is yeah but for Muslims
yeah and then they would like show me
video then like performer extras is it
like the movies like this Gio's favorite
conversation by the way yo loves go
start I want to go to one does that make
you believe more in the religion more or
for me I'm like is that someone that
just mentally disabled that's going
crazy or someone has mental problems
yeah or is it like a real demon did
something nuts happen in the video like
[ __ ] scandal start floating [ __ ] no it's
not the movies dude nothing supernatural
no no you can't tell if it's
supernatural
I wasn't there I just saw a video
someone was going crazy lurches like
praying video - it's called the Exorcist
yeah well I've also driven through it
Skid Row whoa and seeing crackheads and
stuff doing the same thing yeah got it I
still don't have what a man I don't like
Ouija boards not okay what do you mean
isn't your bag oh oh that's my makeup
bag that was from a makeup company
that's so scary as you brought a Ouija
board in here I do use it if
Nix Nix make up shut up it was one of
the office at the new office and I
literally don't even look in that room
how did you notice that this was scared
last time no we don't [ __ ] with the
demons oh man with them don't open your
body up to be a channel for the spirit
it will follow you
that's why you should be drinking boom
water why do well I haven't yet but I'm
going Ouija board night nope oh come on
Ouija board now what a bunch of down I'm
down I'm down I'm not a [ __ ]
what do we do with you [ __ ] you oh god
I'll do easy with you bro let's do
streams first and then next day if you
really want to get more spiritual you
should do DMT with the Ouija board oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]